good morning John the very first VidCon
I was being interviewed by a television
reporter who at one point was surprised
by something I said and she said to me
you can make money on YouTube how does
that work and I was a little tired and I
was also like super high on VidCon my I
was so excited about online video and
all the stuff that had come together and
so like I did I did not censor myself
well I said something to the effect of
advertising my show has more viewers
than yours does which I did not intend
to be a sick bird just came out like
that was the thing that was true the
answer to that question is complicated
and since I think about YouTube a lot
and I think that we should all be more
open about how all of these things work
let's do it let's talk about how
youtubers make their mom different kinds
of content have to have different kinds
of supports like this right here very
low budget this is just two guys we
could probably subsist on what we call
Adsense and merge Adsense works for
every youtuber as long as you're not
like philosophically opposed to
advertise if you click the little box
when you upload your video YouTube will
sell an ad against it and then it will
split the revenue with you you get 55%
this is kind of wonderful it is not a
common thing among social media sites
though they have started to share some
revenue YouTube started doing it way
back in like 2007 and 2008 it's also
part of why it's such an appealing place
to make stuff and also part of why it's
become harder to break is if there's a
way to make money then people will spend
money to make the content look better so
that they can compete on the platform
anyway YouTube Adsense pretty much stays
at the same level and everybody has
access to that which is really amazing
but at higher levels you start talking
about brand deals maybe endorsement
deals may be really good merch stuff and
even eventually getting support from
someone else to help realize your vision
crash course and scishow we're both
funded by grants from YouTube because
they wanted more high quality stuff on
the site so advertisers would be more
likely to advertise those systems are
really hard to democratize and make
available to everybody now brand deals
are a little bit different they have
started to be available to creators sort
of in the middle class Randle's
basically anytime somebody pays you to
talk about something in a video whether
that's like an audible.com call at the
end or it can be a big elaborate
production in your entire video is about
the topic that the brand wants you to
talk about tube advertising is available
to everybody and it comes in and you
don't have to worry about whether or not
it's going to come in but it's a really
low rate in order to supplement income a
lot of youtubers in addition to having
you know regular jobs also live in Los
Angeles where it's
easier to get gigs acting or hosting and
TV commercials or shows and if you have
more social media followers these days
it can be easier to get that kind of
work which is interesting some youtubers
also make money by touring whether
they're comedians or musicians sometimes
creators will license their content to
other platforms sometimes videos go on
TV and you can make some money that way
and then you have some creators like
Rooster Teeth building their own
subscription platforms and then if you
don't want to make people subscribe you
can also ask them to subscribe through
services like patreon which is extremely
important for shows like sexplanations
for example that gets really bad YouTube
ad rates because advertisers don't want
to be next to the word sex without the
support of patreon patrons that show
couldn't happen at all thing to remember
is that different kinds of content work
better with different kinds of
monetization unlike what I said to that
lady at VidCon 2010 it's not simple it's
gotten a lot more difficult to make your
way on this platform and it has become
more complicated is one of the reasons
why I recently started to think called
the internet creators guild with the
goal of being a resource to connect
creators together to give them
information and to let them have a
unified voice when talking about when
things go wrong and what they would like
to make them happy to be clear I started
this thing but I really don't want to
run and I don't think that I should run
it and I definitely can't honestly I
think that I'm too biased to be in
charge so I am looking forward to
eventually stepping back after a helping
Laura Turner Coffey was one of the most
effective people I've ever met
get established as the executive
director of the organization there is a
lot of value that's created by online
video and as different systems of all
for capturing at least some of that
value it just gets more complicated as
those barriers rise we need to create
systems that keep the benefits of this
revolution accessible to the most people
possible and I hope that the internet
creators guild can play a partner thanks
everybody for listening to this
hopefully it wasn't too inside baseball
John I'll see you on Tuesday